[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اجمل ليالي شهر ليالي الابدار واروع فصول
السنه فصل الربيع اللي حنا عايشين فيه
وليالي الابدار ما تجتمع مع فصل الربيع
الا لايام معدوده على الاصابع ولا تطير
بين ايديك من دون ما تستغله بل وناسه
والكشتات وفلت الحجاج والعرب القدماء
يسمون الربيعه صيفا ومنه قولهما الصيف
ضيعت اللبن فالحياه فرص لا تدوم ولا تستمر
واقتناصها مطلب والعامه يقولون ما تبت
الربيع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وللربيع اهميه بالغه عند العرب ولهذا
جعلوا ربيع اول وربيع ثاني في سنتهم
والليالي المبدره لها اهميه خاصه عند
العامه ولهذا جعلوا لها حسابا خاصا بها
قمره رطب وقمره عنب وقمره مشمش وقمره ما
ماش شهر ناكل فيها الرطب وشهرا ناكل فيها
العنب وشهر ناكل فيها المشمش وشهر ناكل
فيها الماماش اللغه الرز الحساوي اتاك
الربيع الطلق يحتال ضاحكا من الحسن حتى
كاد ان
يتكلم
[موسيقى]